The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: And so I want to
thank you all for coming.
As the holiday season
comes along here
I'm guessing that our
people are getting
distracted with other things.
So a little bit more of
an intimate setting today.
So I urge people to
take advantage of that,
ask questions.
It's often a lot easier
to do when there aren't
as many people in the room.
So I just really want to
encourage you to do that.
So let's get right into this.
All right.
Fortunately the mic
actually doesn't pick that
up at all for the most part.
But if you all can hear
the drilling of a-- yeah.
All right, so this is Lecture 4.
I kinda went out of order to get
our special Halloween lecture
in last time.
But we're going to
talking a little bit more
about the analysis of what
we call structured data.
And we're doing more
structured type analyzes
on unstructured data.
And of course the signal
processing on databases,
this is where we bring the
ideas of detection theory
and apply them to
the kinds of data
we see in databases, strings,
and other types of things
there.
And so this lecture is going
to talk a little bit more
about-- we're going to
get into a little bit
more sophisticated analytics.
I think up to this point we've
done a fairly simple thing,
basic queries using
the technology, pretty
simple correlations,
pretty simple stuff.
Now we're going to
begin to kind of go
a little bit more sophisticated
in some of the things we do.
And again, I think as things
get more complicated the deform
technology becomes, its benefits
become even more apparent.
So we're just going to
get right into this,
gonna show you our
very generic scheme,
gonna talk a little bit more
about some of the issues
that we encounter when we deal
with particular databases.
But the database we're going
to be using for this course
is called accumulo.
And so I'll be talking
about some issues that
are more accumulo specific.
So accumulo is a triple store.
And so the way we read
data into our triple store
is using what we call this
exploded transpose pair schema.
So we have-- [INAUDIBLE].
We have an input
data set that might
look like a table like
this with maybe our row key
is going to be
somehow based on time,
and then we have various columns
here, which may or may not
contain various data.
And then the first thing
we do is we basically
explode, because our triple
stores can hold an arbitrary
number of columns.
It can add columns
dynamically without any costs.
We explode this
schema by appending
our Column 1 and its value
together in this way.
We then just took a
value, could be anything,
like one, anything that we
wouldn't want a search on.
And then we have a row key here.
I'll get into back a
little bit why we've
done the row key in this way.
And so by itself this doesn't
give us any real advantage.
But in accumulo or any
other triple store end
or in just in D form
sociative arrays,
we can store the transpose
of the table, which
means that all these
columns are now rows.
And this particular database
is a row oriented database,
which means it can look up any
row key with constant access.
So it can look up row
keys very quickly.
And D4M a lot we
hide this from you
so that whenever you
do inserts it does,
if you want it to
happen, it will
store the transpose for you.
And so you look like you
have a giant table where
you can look up any row key or
any column very, very quickly
and makes it very easy to do
very complicated analytics.
One little twist here
that you may have noticed
is that I have flipped
this time field here,
taking it from
essentially little endian
and made it big endian.
And I've always been an
advocate of having row keys that
have some meaning in them.
Sometimes in databases they just
create your arbitrary random
hashes.
I think we have enough
random data in the world
that we don't necessarily
need to create more,
and so if we can have
meaning in our row keys,
I think it's very
useful, because it just
makes it that much
easier to debug
data that actually has meaning.
And so I've often advocated
for creating having
a row key be a timelike key.
I think it's good to
have timelike keys.
And by itself
there's nothing wrong
with having a little
endian row key,
except when you go parallel.
If this database is actually
running on a parallel system,
you can run into some issues.
People have run into
these issues, which
is why I now advocate
essentially doing
something else with the
row key more like this.
In particular, accumulo,
like many databases,
when it goes parallel
it takes the tables
and it splits them up.
And it splits them
up by row keys.
So it creates continuous
blocks of row keys
on different processors.
If you have a little
endian time row key,
it means every single insert
will go to the same processor.
And that will
create a bottleneck.
And then what will
happen over time
it will then migrate that
data to the other processor.
So it can be a real bottleneck
if you have essentially
a little endian row key.
If you have a big endian
row key, if it just uses,
it will then break
up these things.
And then when you insert your
data, it will sort of naturally
just cause that to spread
out over all the systems.
So that is if your data
is coming in in some kind
of time order, which happens.
We definitely see people
coming in that yesterday,
you know, today's
data comes in today
and tomorrow's data
comes in tomorrow.
You don't want to have it
all that data just hitting
one processor or one compute
node in your parallel database.
Other databases have more
sophisticated distribution
things they can use as
sort of a round robin
or a modular type of--
they'll create a hash that
does a modular so that
it doesn't have that,
eliminates that type of hotspot.
But for now we just recommend
that people use this.
This does make it
difficult to use the row
key as your actual time value.
And so what you would
want to do is also stick,
have a column called time that
had the actual time in it.
And then you could
actually directly look up
a time in that way.
So that's just a
little nuance there,
good sort of design feature.
Probably something
that you wouldn't
run into for quite a while, but
we've definitely had people,
hey I went off and
implemented exactly the way
you suggested, but now
I'm going paralyzed
seeing this bottleneck.
And I'm like oh.
So I'm going to try and correct
that right now and tell people
that this is the
right way to do it.
So starting out
simple, we're just
going to talk about kind of one
of the simplest analytics you
can do, which is getting
basic statistical information
from your data set.
So if this is our data set,
now we have a bunch of row keys
here, timelike with
some additional stuff
to make them
unique, unique rows.
And then we have
these various columns
here, some of which-- the
gray ones are, I'm saying,
are filled in, and the
white ones are empty.
And so what I want to do is
just grab a chunk of rows.
OK, and then I'm going
to compute basically
how many times each column
appears, essentially some.
I'll sum by type.
So I'll show you how
we can look at if you
want to compute just
how many entries there
were in column 1 or column
2, computing the covariance,
computing type and para
covariances are all
different things that we can do.
So I'm going to do all those
statistics on the next slide.
All those analytics,
which if you
were to do them in another
environment would actually be,
you would write a
fair amount of code.
But here we can do them
and each one of them
is essentially a one liner.
So here's my set of row keys.
OK?
I've just created
a list of row keys
that have essentially a
comma as the separator here.
And there, service that.
And this is our Table
T. So in the notation
we often just
refer Table T. This
is in a binding to
an Accumulator Table
or it could be any table really,
any database that we support.
And so this little
bit of code here
says, return me all the rows
given by this list of rows here
and all the columns.
So we're using the
Matlab notation.
Colon means return
all the columns.
This will then
return these results
in the form of an
associative array.
Now since the values
of that are strings,
in this case maybe
strings values of 1,
we have this little
function here
called double logi,
which will just basically
say ignore whatever the
value is and just make it--
if it's got an entry, give it
a 1 or otherwise ignore it.
So this is a shorthand.
It basically does a logical,
and then it does a double,
so we can do math on it.
So this is our query
that gets us our rows
and returns them as
an associative array
with numeric values.
We then compute
the column counts.
So that's just the
Matlab sum command,
which says basically this
tells you the dimension that's
being compressed.
So it's compressing the first
dimension with the rows.
So it's basically collapsing
it into a row vector.
So it's just summing.
So I just would tell us now we
could then for all those rows
count how many occurrences
of each unique column,
of each column type there was.
And then we can then
get the covariance,
the type type covariance by just
doing A transpose A or square
in.
These do the same thing.
This is usually slightly
faster but not a lot.
And so that just does the column
type, column type, covariance,
very simple.
And then finally we have this
function, which essentially
undoes our exploded schema.
So let's say we
wanted to return it
back to the original
dense format
where we have essentially four
columns, column 1, 2, 3, and 4.
And we wanted to value put
back into the value position.
So we have this function
call to type with this--
and I don't know if
the name makes sense
or not, but that's what we call
it-- and basically just says,
oh, this is the limiter.
So it takes each one of
those, splits it back out,
and stuffs it back in.
And so then you now have
that associative array.
You can then do a
sum again on that
to just get like I
want to know just how
many column 1 instances,
column 2 instance,
column 3s there are.
And likewise, just doing
A transpose A or square in
would then do the
covariance of that.
And that would tell you
of those higher level
types how many of there were.
So this is a lot of
high level information.
Really highly recommend that
people do this when they first
get their data,
because it really
uncovers a lot of bad data
right from the get go.
You'll discover columns
that are just like,
wow these two column types
never appear together.
And that doesn't make sense.
There's something wrong there.
Or why is this exploded column,
why is it so common when
that doesn't make sense?
So again, it's very, very
useful for doing things.
And we always recommend people
start with this analytic.
So again, that's
very simple stuff.
We've talked about it before.
Let's talk about some
more sophisticated types
of analytics that
we can do here.
So I'm going to build
what I call a data graph.
So this is just a
graph in the data.
It may not actually be a real.
You may have some
other graph in mind,
but this is the data supports
as a particular kind of graph
in it.
So what we're
going to do here is
we're going to set a couple
starting column here.
OK, C0, that'll be our
set of starting columns.
And we're going to set a column.
I said I've allowed
column types.
So we're going to be interested
in certain column types.
And we're going to create
a set of clutter columns.
These are columns that
we want to ignore.
We want to-- they're either
very, very large or whatever.
And so the basic
algorithm is that we're
going to get all the columns.
Our result is going
to be called C1 here.
OK, and that's going to be all
rows in C0 that are of type CT,
and excluding columns CL.
So this is a rather complicated
joined type of thing
that people often want to do.
They want to do these
types of things.
Look, I want to
get all these rows,
but I only care about these
particular types of columns.
And I don't really
care about, or I
want to expressively eliminate
certain clutter columns
that I know are just like
always pointing everywhere.
So let's go look through
the D4M Code that
does this sort of
complicated type of join.
So I'm going to
specify my C0 here.
And this could be a whole list.
It's just the whole list
of starting columns.
I'm going to specify
my column types.
In this case I'm going
to have two column types.
I'm gonna say, create a
string called starts with,
which essentially
creates a column range,
one column range
around column 1,
and one column range
around column 3.
And then I'm going to specify
a clutter column here,
which is just this
A. And again, it
could be a whole list as well.
All right, so step one
here is I'm going to pass.
I'm assuming that
this table is bound
to one of these exploded
transposed pairs.
So it will know when
I give it columns
to look up to then point
to the correct table.
So we have a C0 here.
And it will say, all right,
please return all rows,
all the data that contains
C0, basically all those rows.
I'm then going to say now I
don't care about their values,
I just want the rows.
So this is an associative array,
and this command row just says,
just give me those rows.
So basically I had a column,
I returned all the rows,
but now I just
want the row keys.
I'm now going to
take those row keys
and pass them back
into the row position.
So now I will have
gotten the entire row.
So basically I got a
column, I took those rows,
and now I'm going and striping
and painting and getting
the whole rows.
So now I have every single.
And since I don't care
about the actual values,
I just want them to
be numeric, I just
use the double logi command.
So basically I've done a
rather complicated little piece
of query here in terms of get
me all columns that contain,
all rows that contain
a certain column.
And so that's now an
associative array.
I'm then going to reduce to
specific allowed columns.
So I'm going to pass in.
I'm going to say,
please give me just
the ones of these
particular column types.
So I got the whole row, but now
I just want to eliminate those.
I could have probably
actually put this in here,
but whether it's more efficient
or not to do it here or here,
it's 6 of one, half
dozen of the other.
I try and make my
table queries just
either only columns
or only rows.
It tends to make things simpler.
So now we do that.
We have just those types.
And now I want to eliminate
the clutter columns.
So I have A, which is
just of these type.
And I want to then eliminate
any of the columns that are
in this, basically, column 1.
So I had column 1
as one of my types,
but I don't care about that.
And so I can just
do subtraction.
I can just basically say, oh
go get the clutter columns
and subtract them from
the data that I have.
And now I'm just going
to get those columns,
and I have now the
set of columns.
I now have C1.
So I've completed
the analytic I just
described in the-- if you're
grabbing like four lines rather
sophisticating analytic,
I could then proceed
to look for additional clutter.
For instance, I could
then basically query say,
please give me those, stick
the C1 back in and then
sum it up and look for things
that had a lot of values
and continue this process.
Just an example of
something I might
want to do when I
have this data set.
So these show you the kinds of
more sophisticated analytics
that you can do.
I want to talk a little
bit about data graphs
in terms of what are the
things you can do here,
what is supported.
The topology of
your data, remember
this edge list has direction.
When you have graphs
they can very well
have edges that have direction.
And a lot of times
people will say,
well I want to get
the whole graph.
I'm like, well, if you're
doing essentially things that
are based on breadth
first search,
you may not be able
to get the full graph,
because you're never going at
it from the correct direction.
So you are definitely limited
by the natural topology
of your data.
So for example here, let's say
I start with C0 as column 1A.
So I now have essentially
this vertex A let's call it.
And now here I say, OK,
I now want to get all.
Give me the whole row
of all I'm going to do.
Give me all the rows
that contain that.
All right, so then
these two guys pop up.
So I get another A and I
get a B. So I got a B here.
That's good.
And then I'm going to go,
proceed, go down again.
I'm like, all right.
I'm going to then now say,
give me all the rows that
contain those columns.
And I go down again, and I
got the C. Did I get a C?
No, I never got a C. I never
got a C in any one of these,
even though it's all in the
data and probably all connected.
I never actually got a C.
There I got the C. Now when
I did it the second time
I got the C, so there we go.
So this is an
example of a series
of breadth first
searches that result
in getting the whole graph.
But the graph had this
typology and wouldn't naturally
admit that.
So certainly in this particular
case the data and the queries
were good for this,
we would call a star,
because essentially
it's a vertex
with everything going into it.
Let's take a different graph.
This is what we call a cycle.
So we see we have a little
cycle here going like this.
We start again with
A. We get our columns.
We get C1s across here.
And that's kind of
the end of the game.
We get A's, we get
a B, but we're not
going to get anything else
when we column back up.
We're not going to
get anything else.
And so we're
basically stuck here
at B. We weren't able
to get to C or D.
So these are the kind of a
little more subtle things
that everyone has
to worry about.
And once you see it it's
kind of, well, of course.
I can't do-- I'm not going
to get the whole graph.
But you'd be amazed how
many teams were like,
I wanted the whole graph,
and I just can't do it.
It's like, well, you
don't have the edges going
in the right direction
for you to do that.
You're going to
have to think things
through a little bit more.
So I just want to-- it's
kind of a little catch
that I want to point out to
people, because it's something
that people can run into.
We're going to do a little
different type of analytic
here.
I've changed some
of my columns here.
I have some.
Let's call these coordinates.
I'm going to have
now with my data
set an x and a y-coordinate that
I'm storing in different rows
and columns.
I want to do some kind
of space windowing.
I want to find all data within
a particular x and y-coordinate.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to select a set of data
here R instead of rows.
And I'm going to
give a space polygon.
query, get the data.
And then I'm going to
extract the space coordinates
from the values
there, and I'm gonna
return all columns that are
within my space window here.
And again, this is good
for finding columns
in between your space window.
If you're concerned
that you're going
to be getting an awful
lot of if you have,
let's say you have a coordinate
that goes through New York.
And you're concerned
that's just going
to-- you don't want to get,
you don't want New York,
but you happen to be
on the same latitude
and longitude of New York.
You can do something called
Mertonization, which basically
is essentially imagine
taking your strings
of your coordinates
and interleaving them.
And now you've essentially
created an Ascii based grid
of the entire planet.
And so that's a way of if you
want to quickly filter down,
you can get a box
and then go back
and do the detailed
coordinates to vent yourself
from having to do.
So that's a standard trick.
And there's a variety
of Mertonization schemes
that people use for interleaving
coordinates in this way.
I think Google Earth has a
standard box now as well.
I find this the simplest,
because you literally just
take the two strings
and interleave them.
And if you have a space,
you can actually then
do with variable precision,
because if you just like,
space I don't know.
And it all kind of
works out pretty nicely.
And you can read the
coordinate right there.
Like, the first
one is the first.
And you can even include the
plus and minus signs for a lot
if you wanted to.
So maybe not the most efficient
scheme, but one that's human
readable.
And I'm a big advocate of human
readable types of data schemes.
All right, so let's
actually do that analytic.
So again, I created
my-- selected my row,
got my x and y-coordinates
in those rows,
and then figured out which
columns they were that
satisfied that.
So let's do that now in code.
Let's see here.
So we have the-- all
right, so we have,
in this case I gave
It a row range.
So you can do-- this is what
a range query looks like.
If you give any, either an
associative array or a table,
something that is a triple,
essentially that's a string,
colon, and another
string, it will
treat that as a range query.
And we actually
support doing if you
have multiple sets
of triples, it
should handle that,
which is good.
I'm going to specify my bounding
box here, essentially a box.
And I happen to do
with complex numbers
just for fun, just because
complex numbers are a nice way
to store coordinates on
a two dimensional plane.
And Matlab supports
them very nicely.
Complex numbers are our
friends, so there you go.
But I could have just as easily
had a set of x and y vectors.
So I'm going to
get all the rows.
So I query that.
Very good, we have that.
And then, so that
just gives me that set
of data, all those rows.
I then use my starts with my x
and y to get just the columns
of those X's and Y's.
And I'm now kind of going to
convert those exploded back
into a regular table with
this call to type function.
So that basically
takes those values.
So it takes those coordinate
values, so like we saw.
It takes these coordinate
values here like the 0 1,
and it puts it back
into the value position.
So now I have,
though, it will still
be a string in the
value position, which
our associate arrays
can handle fine.
But I now want to really
treat it like a number.
So we just have overloaded
the standard Matlab string
to numb function, which
will convert those strings
and will store them back.
You now have an associated
array with numbers in them.
So we call this Axy.
And now we can do something.
We basically can extract
the x values here.
So we have Axy,
and say, all right,
give me the x column, and then
Axy and give me the y column.
And Matlab has a built in
function called in polygon,
which you give it a polygon.
So I give it the real
and the imaginary parts
of my polygon here S and
the x and y-coordinates.
And it will return in
essentially the value
of is that in there,
which is great,
because there are many
dissertations written
on the in polygon problem.
And it's nice that we have a
nice built in Matlab function
to do that.
And then now I have that,
and I can just pass that back
into the original
A. So I do find.
This actually returns a
logical of zeros and ones.
If I do find, then that will
return a set of indices.
And I just pass those
indices back into A.
And then I can get
those columns and there
we go, all very standard
Matlab like syntax.
Again, this is a fairly
complicated analytic.
If you were doing this
using other technologies,
I mean, I'm sure
all of us would be
writing a fair amount of code.
And this is just
the kind of thing
that we can do
very easily in D4M.
Another analytic, which is
probably a bit of a stretch,
but I was just having fun
here, is doing convolution
on strings, which
is a little odd.
But I gave it I gave it a whirl.
So what we want to do is we want
to convolve some of our data
with a filter.
I mean, convolving the filters
as a standard type of thing.
So it's the standard way
we do detection here.
And so the way we do
that is once again,
I give a list of rows
that I want here.
I'm going to create a filter,
which is just essentially
a box of 4 wide box.
So I get my rows.
And then I convert
them to numeric.
And I'm going to do my
convolution on the x columns.
So let's see here.
So I'm going to get these.
I'm basically getting
all the x-coordinates.
I'm going to sum all of
those, so I basically now
have all those.
And now I'm going to pop
those back into their values.
And now I can do a convolution.
And this convolution
works if one of the axes
is sort of like an integer
sequence type of thing.
So you can do-- it tries
to extend that naturally.
So something to play around with
if you want to do convolutions.
We sort of support it.
And I'm sure if anyone
of you do play around it,
we would be glad to
hear your experiences,
think about how we
should extend it.
So these are all sort of
basic standard first order
statistical analytics that
one can do on data sets.
And we can support
them very, very well.
Let's do some more complicated
what I would call second order
analytics.
So I'm going to do
something called,
it's a complicated
join essentially,
what I call a type pair.
So what I want to
do here is I want
to find all rows
that contain values.
I want to find rows that
have both value of type 1
and of type 2.
So I'm going to specify this
to be, basically x to be type 1
and y to be type 2.
And I want to find
all data that has
entries in both those
very, very standard type
of join type of thing.
And this is done a little
bit more complicated
than we need it to be
just to show you kind
of some of the richness here.
You can kind of take
a fork in any way.
We could probably do this
whole thing in about two lines,
but I'm kind of showing you
some additional features of D4M
in the spirit of this analytic.
So again, I'm just going
to use a range query here.
So I have this range.
I'm going to have my type 1 be
starts with x, and my type 2
be starts with y.
So I do my query.
I convert all the string
1's to numeric 1's.
And then what I'm
going to do is I'm
going to basically, all right,
get me all the columns of type
1, sum them all together,
find everything that equals--
and I only care about the
1's that are exactly equal 1.
So like if I had two
x's, I'm like no.
I don't want those.
I want exactly
one x in this row.
And then I'm going to take those
rows that have exactly one x.
I'm going to pass
them back into A.
So I now just get the rows
that have exactly one x.
I'm going to filter it
again with ct1 and ct2,
although, I don't
need to do that.
Then I'm going to sum it again.
And now I'm going
to say, all right,
give me the only ones
that are exactly 2.
So I know my x is exactly 1.
So in order for it to be
exactly 2, that means my y also
had to have only
exactly one entry in it.
So now I have the
data that just has
exactly one of each of those.
Now I want to create sort of
like a cross-correlation pair
mapping of this.
So I'm actually to look
for x's across columns
that appear say, I
want to look for x's
that appear with more
than one y or a y that
appears with more than one x.
So there's a variety
of ways to do that.
Here what I'm doing is-- so I
have gotten the rows of A that
have exactly one x and y.
I now pass that back again to
get my C, to get the x's again.
And one of the things that
we've done that's kind of nice
is we've overloaded the
syntax of this query
on our associated arrays
and on our table queries
such that if it only
has one argument,
it will return an
associative array.
But if you give it
three output arguments,
it will return the triple, so in
this case, the row, the column,
and the value.
Now I don't care about
the row and the value,
I just care about the column.
But that's a nice way.
We're often gonna
in certain cases
want to bump back
and forth between
the triples representation
and the associated array
implementation.
Now you always can
use the Find command
around any associated array
just as you can in normal Matlab
matrices not return the triple.
The advantage of
doing it here is
that it's faster,
because what we actually
do when we do the
query internally
is we actually get the
triples and then convert
to an associative array.
And if you just say
I want the triples,
we can just short cut that
and give you the triples
right away.
So sometimes if you're
dealing with a very large
associative arrays or
some operation that's just
I want to get some more
performance back then working.
Especially if you like, well,
I only care about one thing,
I don't care about
all of the values,
I don't really need to be
a full associative array,
then that's a great way to
sort of short circuit that.
So we do that here.
And now we can construct
a new associate array,
which is just taking the
x's and the y's and creating
a new associative
array with those.
And that just shows me
the correlations between
the x's and the y's.
And I can then find ct,
basically x's that have more
than one y-- so I've
just summed them there--
or y's with more than one x's.
Again, these are very
similar to analytics
that people want to do.
And again, very simple to do.
And again, showing you some of
the different types of syntax
that are available
to you in D4M.
Again, if you're used to using
Matlab, these types of tricks
are very natural.
We're just showing you that
they also exist within D4M.
So here's another one.
So I wanted to find column
of pair set C1 and C2,
and get all columns C1 and C2,
and find the rows that have
just one entry in C1 and C2.
And it basically checks
to see if data pairs are
present in the same row.
Again, something that
people often want to do.
You've got a complicated
type of join.
So here we have a set of columns
one C1, a set of column C2.
I want to create this, I want
to sort of interleave these
together into a pair.
So I want to create
some concept of a pair.
And so we have
this function here
called cat string,
which basically
will take two strings
and another delimiter,
and will basically if they are
of the same number of strings
will just leave them together.
If one of these is
just a single string,
it will just an essentially
preappend or append that.
So for instance, if you are
wondering how we actually
create these exploded
values like call 1 and B,
that's just basically
using this function here.
We get the values,
we get the columns,
we put essentially the
pipe thing in the middle,
and it just merges
them together.
So we now sort of interleave
these two together.
So we'll now have something
like Col1 b pipe Col3
b pipe comma as the separator.
So now I can create a
set of pair mappings
from C1 to its pairs.
OK, that's A1 to its pairs
and A2 to it's pairs.
I can get the columns
of those A1 and A2.
And then I can find all
the pairs by essentially
through this combination of
matrix multiplies and additions
and etc.
So a very sort of complicated
analytic done very nicely.
And then there's a whole
bunch of different ones
you can do here.
These are almost
semantic extension.
The column types may have
several different types,
and you want to do.
So for instance, if I have
a pair of columns here,
column 1 and column
3, I could say, well,
that also implies this.
Column three equals column 1.
That's one kind of sort of
pair reversal type of thing.
You'll have extensions.
You might say, look
if I have a column
1A that also implies
that really there
should also be a column
2A, and other types
of things like that.
So these are just
types of things
that people do with pairs.
They're often very useful.
And I think that
basically brings us
to the end of the
lecture portion of class.
So again, just the
exploited schema
really allows you to do this
very rapidly with your data.
And you can implement a very
efficient graph analytics
as a sequence of essentially
row and column queries,
because we use this very special
exploded transpose pair schema.
And increasingly as you
become more and more skilled
with this, you will discover
that many, many, many
of your analytics really reduce
to matrix matrix multiplies.
That matrix matrix
multiply really
captures the whole
sort of all correlation
that you want to do without
having to kind of figure things
out.
All right, so I'm now
going to go and show some
not these specific
analytics, but some analytics
that are more sophisticated
based on the Reuters data set.
If you remember a
few weeks ago, we
worked with the
Reuters data set.
And so let's see here.
So we already did the
entity analysis application
a few weeks ago.
I'm going to now
do basically what
happens when you
construct tracks,
which is a more sophisticated
structured analytic.
And the assignment I'll
send out was basically
doing more cross correlations.
For those of you who have
kept it going here this far
and continue to
do the homeworks,
I'll send this
homework out to you,
which is basically
just cross correlating
the data sets that you have.
Again, and not an assignment
that really predispose
requires you having done
the previous assignments.
Just any data set, pull it
into an associate array,
and then do matrix
multiplies to figure out
the cross correlations
and what they mean.
All right, so with
that, why don't we
take a short five minute break.
And then I'll come back
and show you the demo.